[Music]
there's a significant development a
major breakthrough if true kim jungeun
is signalling he is willing to
denuclearize North Korea if the US
agrees to talks the surprising news came
out of a meeting between the dictator
and a South Korean delegation president
Trump reacting today with cautious
optimism we have come certainly a long
way at least rhetorically with North
Korea it would be a great thing for the
world it would be a great thing for
North Korea it would be a great thing
for the peninsula but we'll see what
happens we have made progress there's no
question about it
the president also crediting sanctions
as a motivation for North Korea to come
to the table I think that they are
sincere but I think they're sincere also
because the sanctions and what we're
doing with respect to North Korea
including you know the great help that
we've been given from China and they can
do more I really believe they are
sincere I hope this since here we're
going to soon find out so the president
taking a cautious approach a little bit
skeptical but optimistic not everyone
feels the same way John Bolton former UN
Ambassador had this to say look the only
thing North Korea is serious about is
getting deliverable nuclear weapons and
by all accounts they are very close to
achieving an objective they've been
after for 25 years so why do they want
to talk now I will bet you a dollar just
as we're sitting here today you're going
to hear almost immediately the United
States has to has to contribute to the
atmosphere we've got to show good faith
let's prime the pump all of which is
code talk for make concessions and if
that comes that I think you can count on
this North Korea will get deliverable
nuclear weapons before the end of this
year so John Bolton basically having
some pretty frank talk there Gregg on
North Korea he's skeptical yeah and I
think I think it's good to be skeptical
it's good to be skeptical but even if
what North Korea said is baloney it's
actually new baloney and skepticism
should it should always be where you're
from but what would you rather hear than
this I mean what would you like if
you're actually hearing something
positive well I mean sure you'd like him
to say we're gonna
labor camps and we're gonna go to a free
market system but in the spectrum of
positive shifts this is actually pretty
good and it is new it's I mean they're
talking about getting together South
Korea for the first time in ten years I
don't think they've ever talked about
denuclearization as part of this plan if
this happened under Obama the Nobel
Peace Prize would have been shipped
Amazon Prime next day OneTouch delivery
and and so I will take I think you know
I thought I thought Trump's response was
pretty yea pretty reserved and said you
know look that could happen could not
happen but you know I'll take him at
their word for now see what happens but
we all know both Bolton this down the
line he's very consistent on this stuff
yeah just like that's why he won't shave
that mustache and the president I think
rightly saying Jesse that one of the
ways reasons you have this new
development no matter how it turns out
is because the sanctions are starting to
have an effect right rocket man's crazy
and he's very slick so this could just
be a ploy for a cash infusion but at the
same time it's a positive development as
Gregg said where are the Democrats
because the Democrats have been saying
that all this tough talk would lead to
war and all we need to do is sit down at
the table and have negotiations and
diplomacy well Trump has now gotten this
to the point of potential diplomacy and
talks I don't hear anything from the
Democrats the Democrats will never give
anybody credit especially Donald Trump
when something happens positive for the
American people and this is I think both
parties are responsible for this you
know Pelosi they call the tax cuts
crumbs you know Harry Reid wouldn't even
admit that the surge worked there were
Republicans that it wouldn't give Obama
credit for killing bin Laden I get that
but the media said that this would lead
to war the fire and fury and all these
war games so the media should be
completely discredited because it led to
the opposite and it's because they don't
report cause and effect President Trump
says some things and all of a sudden
border crossings are down or you know
NATO countries are ponying up money Isis
is decimated these were the results of
Trump rhetoric actions and policy but
the media won't tell you the whole story
they're only reporting things in
isolation because they're just dishonest
I haven't heard the Democrats say
anything
give them anything positive or negative
it seems like it's been pretty quiet
although it just did happen today right
you know I listen to Jessie so closely
so I here's what I have to say to your
audience and seem like when if it's snow
if it snows in Boston or New York City
in the next two days Donald Trump is
right about global warming when he is
talking about my buttons bigger than
your button and you will get devastated
we will wipe you off there when you are
talking that one way to someone who we
agree is a bit of a nutcase right kim
jeong-hoon Americans are right to worry
why is our president engaging at that
level with someone who is impetuous and
also bring us to now for the first time
and I finish that I think your leaders
not going to go this has nothing to do
with Donald Trump's rhetoric the better
case to be made is it has something to
do with sanctions and the effect we've
had in trying to get China and others
including Russia reluctantly that's not
this is a result the administration has
said as much they didn't like the idea
of the two SOT the two Koreas marching
together at the Olympics they didn't
like the idea of a president moon of
South Korea engaging in talks
independently potentially undercutting
us efforts to put pressure on North
Korea and now you get a result of the
South don't don't sit here and say it's
not without possible concerns right so
there are several things that happening
for example we don't have an ambassador
in South Korea we don't have a system
secretary for Asian affairs thank you
that's true oh my god what will we do I
was just thinking we don't have one of
those well my point is that you have an
opportunity for diplomacy here and so
the Trump administration would want to
have reinforcements there especially if
one of the goals of North Korea is to
split off South Korea
from its strong alliance with the United
States that was what I was trying to say
yeah and well stated very positive that
you know really the Democrats
Republicans independents undecideds
whatever you are unready just hurt I
don't know you would be happy about this
because why wouldn't you want to have an
attempt at least at thoughtful
you know consistent negotiations to try
to work on eliminating reducing the
threat of nuclear war if they are
willing to come to the table and they
are sincere and earnest and we will give
it a very discerning eye indeed as an
ambassador Bolton had said why not sit
at the table with them make that effort
make that attempt if the president
didn't put out a tweet like this you
would see the Liberals the Dems going
screaming why aren't you giving peace
Newtown to say yeah give peace a chance
you just are trigger-happy you want to
put your finger on the button it's crazy
if he said and said little rocket man
says he wants to negotiate doubt it how
they do this
ever since the North Korea since the
beginning of the administration there's
kind of a good cop bad cop saying it let
me read to you Greg what Rex Tillerson
said today I love ray which is that
North Korea threatens the entire global
community through its unlawful nuclear
and ballistic missiles blah blah blah it
must be a global effort basically he's
trying here's the heavy yes that the
thing is and it and it was part of the
kind of like the whole idea of what
Trump was talking about with Isis and
stuff unpredictability it's it's kind of
nice when America is the quote crazy
person on the Block we all the time
we've been the person that the crazy
person says death to America now we're
the unpredictable person and the
unpredictability actually reset the
table with North Korea and has reset the
table in other areas as well if you look
in certain things even with the
immigration like we don't know what's
coming and things change because of that
but I disagree I don't think that that
kim jeong-hoon
is crazy i think he's a rational actor
and this is what he's doing to make sure
that he survives because i think he gets
the he get I think he's figuring out
that this is going into a different
phase and when he says something like we
will do nuclear retires if we feel that
if we feel that you guys aren't going to
nuke us and if you feel
that's actually a rational statement
like Bolton says though he could be
lying but the thing is Jesse's point
which is true and to Kimberly you don't
have to like Donald Trump to admit now
and then that progress is made no none
of your friends are gonna think less of
you because you can't admit that he
actually did something pretty good
problem is he's done five pretty good
things this year yeah like what take a
mom with the tax cuts you want to talk
with no one here the five no five what
John Bolton has real significance I'd
agree eighty-five years of the North
Koreans making what looks like oh let's
have some talks we're grill our reactors
months ago Wong what it talks about
everything else the president doesn't
trust them also he said we're ready to
go hard either way if they if they try
to play you know slippery with us but
here's the deal they they duped Bush
they duped Carter I think Trump's going
in there with wide and clear eyes and if
they try to wiggle out of this or if
this is just a hand out attempt then
he's gonna get out of there that's
rational wouldn't you agree
yeah if you were to me the important
thing is here to protect American
interest in that region and I think
that's difficult but I don't think that
he and which is what you argued cause
this me okay maybe Rex Tillerson did it
all okay who's part of the no he was
joking he's joking it's not Rex it's the
South Korean president oh yes this horse
to death